so that's what pandora actually looks
like james cameron's avatar is one of
the most visually stunning films ever
made but what does it look like without
all the cgi the animators have taken
what the actors are doing and gone even
beyond that natieri lives a pretty
unique lifestyle as one of the navi on
the planet of pandora one of the things
that we see nati partake in is drinking
water from a leaf but because director
james cameron loves to rely on
technology innovation the way that the
scene was actually filmed without cgi
may surprise you zoe saldana was
required to work with a grey plastic
contraption to model as the leaf while
holding a water bottle covered in duct
tape to simulate water coming from the
tape we guess that's why they call it
movie magic it's the most high-tech film
in terms of its execution you may or may
not have had an awkward kiss in your
life but it probably wasn't as awkward
as it was for sam worthington and zoe
saldana when they had to kiss as jake
and nati while filming avatar while in
the movie itself with all the added cgi
the scene plays out romantically without
all the cgi worthington and saldana had
to kiss with their motion captured
jumpsuits and with green dots all over
their face so that the motion capture on
their character's cgi bodies would be
accurate and more real we created a
manually operated gimbal rig
that they could balance on one of the
most exciting action scenes in all of
avatar was definitely the flying banshee
obviously a lot of cgi was needed to be
done to bring the banshee to life as
there's no living real world counterpart
to the creature in order to capture jake
flying on the banshee sam worthington
was required to fly on the back of a
moving plastic structure where he'd be
flung around with wires all while
wearing the motion capture suit honestly
we think we'd just prefer the ride at
disney world that seems a bit more
comfortable
seeing them flying these things they are
working hard it's always intense
whenever anybody in a movie yells but
when a blue skinned alien like nathiri
yells it's even more powerful
you will never be one of the people
despite the goofy motion capture getup
and the silly plastic navi ears saldana
was still able to be quite intimidating
on set layers of additional cgi were
added in order to make nativi and the
rest of the navi look even more real in
the film you definitely wouldn't want to
take natiri off
i at least have no idea that i'm wearing
this i feel like i'm blue and i'm nine
feet tall the big villain of avatar was
stephen lang's colonel miles kworich who
unlike a lot of the other characters who
required cg is actually a human one
might assume that the colonel's mech
suit design was all cgi but they would
be wrong the main core design of the
suit was a practical effect but it was
the arm and the digital screens that
were later added with additional cgi
work in order to make the suit a more
formidable force to the navi the final
product proved to be quite the treat to
the navi and made lang's colonel an even
more memorable villain with rumors that
he'll be back for the sequel he may even
bring that neck suit back
oh yeah who's bad that's right
one of the first dangerous creatures
that jake encounters in the jungles of
pandora is the fierce thanator while the
thanator is quite intimidating on screen
the creature wasn't much to look at
before the cgi was added in fact before
the cgi was added standing in for the
thanator was a red tennis ball on a long
gray stick held by a crew member in
order for the actors to go on cue the
crew member holding the thanators stand
in would lunge at them life on pandora
would likely be much easier if all the
navi had to worry about was a tennis
ball on a stick
cameron has a knack for working with
actors and actresses he's worked with
before so of course one of the actresses
he brought with him to avatar was his
alien star sigourney weaver weaver plays
grace in the film and doesn't just play
the character in human form but also as
a navi while even in her navi form grace
typically wears human clothes behind the
scenes weaver had to still wear a motion
capture suit to convincingly play
grace's navi avatar from alien to
ghostbusters sigourney weaver has
clearly made her mark in the sci-fi
genre we had horses galloping around
this place it wasn't just the human
actors who were behind motion capture
technology on the set of avatar as
actual horses were used under motion
capture technology for the dire horses
the horses were equipped with dots on
their body much like their human
co-stars in order for them to be
transformed later with visual effects
the horses were brought to the sound
stage of the film and cameron would film
the actors behind the navi riding the
horses with the special technology that
would allow him to be their cgi
counterparts as they were filming who
knows maybe those horses went on to take
other motion capture roles as well
despite all the extensive cgi and motion
capture present throughout avatar that
didn't mean the actors had to perform
less stunts in fact it was quite the
opposite whenever we saw the navi
climbing up the vines of the ominous
floating rocks on pandora cameron had
the actors behind the navi climb a
similar structure all in their motion
capture gear the final cgi was added
later but still that didn't make the
climb not dangerous though you can't
really become one of the navi without at
least getting a little bit rugged with
yourself and your environment motion
capture wasn't always available when
capturing scenes with the navi
especially when they shared the screen
with the human characters when recording
the scene where jake first wakes up in
his navi form cameron filmed the actors
playing the human doctors working around
an empty gurney behind the lens of
cameron's camera he was able to see the
cgi character we went to
kauai we went way up in the mountains
and we acted out the scenes before the
motion capture work was done for avatar
sam worthington and zoe saldana filmed
without their suits half naked in hawaii
this would be done in order so james
cameron could know how to plan all their
scenes that would need motion capture
such as the bow and arrow scene the tree
of voices is perhaps one of the most
gorgeous looking set pieces in all of
avatar but behind the scenes and without
the cgi that sacred tree wasn't much to
look at in fact the trees were mainly
just pieces of rope that were used to
simulate the long leaves and branches of
the trees that netiri would present to
jake the final cgi would be added into
the production later to say these stunt
guys i mean they really just they gave
us their all the na'vi clearly have a
different culture than what we're used
to and cameron wanted to display some of
the tribal customs of the main tribe in
the film the group of four actors may
not have had the biggest roles in the
film but that didn't mean their work
wasn't difficult these actors ultimately
had to memorize a tribal dance of the
na'vi in all their motion capture suits
now that's true commitment to the craft
if this was cg i could have moved that
30 seconds so the whole time i was
shooting the virtual camera i was
complaining that it wasn't live x while
there were times on set where james
cameron and his crew had more accurate
models of the dragon assault ships there
were times where the models wouldn't be
enough in order to film the scene
cameron had the motion capture board use
a metal-like chair in the middle of the
set that would be moved around by crew
members a fan was also placed in front
of the actors in order to properly
capture the wind blowing in their
characters faces while the real set may
not have been as exciting as actually
flying on a ship as a navi on pandora
the cast and crew certainly made the
most of it they develop the most
lightweight 3d system
possible so it's a very sophisticated
technology the 3d much like the cgi had
to be recorded in a distinct way using
two cameras this scene where the kernel
is attacked on his mech by one of the
navi used two cameras to perfect the 3d
and the cgi one camera would be used for
the live action elements and the other
would be used for the cg 3d elements i
need you to put up 10 million dollars to
prove we can make this movie avatar is
one of the most influential films made
in the last 20 years and the cgi is an
important reason why from cameron's
innovative ways of incorporating the cgi
to the commitment for authenticity by
the cast and crew avatar's production
was clearly top notch what was your
favorite cgi element in james cameron's
avatar